welcome
to everyone and a great congratulations
to everyone who is watching this here on
the live stream this afternoon
congratulations
[Silence]
those followers the companions of the
companions
etc it was their tradition that they
would congratulate one another
whenever the sacred months
would approach or whenever the most
best of times would come upon them
they would congratulate one another and
so based on that
we congratulate everyone we congratulate
ourselves and
first of all we preface this by thanking
allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
that we have reached
another sacred blessed month
the month of ramadan once again in our
lives
we've lost many people since last year
and we've lost many people since the
year before that
and it is a privilege and nothing short
of
a privilege that we have been
chosen by allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
be part of this
year's ramadan so congratulations to
everyone
and we ask allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
the strength and the courage and that he
give us the audacity
to do what is necessary during this
month and not to squander this
opportunity
that we have to today and that we have
for the rest of the month insha'allah
this month of ramadan every month of
ramadan
every month of every year we are to
capitalize
on each day we're to look at each day
at each sunrise as if it is a brand new
life
it's a new life that you're living
you're going to make the best of that
life
and this month is a month that is
blessed according to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he said
it's been narrated that he said the
month of ramadan has come
upon you all and it is a blessed month
now this statement mubarak
blessed what it really translates to
is that it has an abundance of good
and not just an abundance of good but an
abundance of
remnant and permanent good
in it that what you do during this month
will change your life
it will change your life
irrevocably and it will change your life
irreversibly
and that's something that we have to
understand when he says
it means that it is a blessed month that
brings with it an abundance of remnant
and permanent good
and so capitalize on that it doesn't
mean that you have to be perfect
we're not going to be perfect we're
going to fall short
we all are going to in some way or
another slack off it's just how
we as human beings are but we're going
to try our best
and the idea is is that the best
you can try or as i should say
the best you can do is the best that you
can do
so try your best work harder try
to give yourself that little bit of
extra push
this ramadan make this ramadan
better than the last one and if you
achieve that
then you have achieved what is referred
to as sn
in the quran and in the sunnah and that
is that
san is constant progression
that's what sn is constant progression
that every month or every day or
every hour i'm trying to constantly be
better than the previous and if i can
achieve that
then i am on my way to allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
so any chance that you get any
opportunity no matter what it is
even if it is just to smile in someone's
face
and make them feel good even though they
are going through utter misery
you would be amazed what a smile can do
to the human heart
if it comes from the heart if it's not a
superficial one
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said in this spirit
he said do not belittle any good deed
that you can muster
up even if it is merely to meet your
brother with a smiling face
obviously we don't always do that
obviously we have good days and we have
bad days
obviously we have things on our mind but
every time you do something and you have
an
opportunity capitalize on it
work for now and for this moment and i
ask allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that he
make this
ramadan our best
we're going to be going through a series
of verses of the quran
we have four series four installments
this ramadan with myself
this ramadan we are going to focus
on the two chapters of the quran
which are referred to as the two
chapters of ikhlas
the two chapters of total submission to
allah subhanahu wa
and then we're going to do two more
chapters
which speak about the
evils and those things which negate
that utter submission to allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
their chapters their verses of the quran
we've memorized
most of us anyways have memorized all if
not
many if not all of these chapters
but we want to look at them
under a different light and we want to
look at them
in a different way that perhaps we may
gain some new enlightenment and
as the poet has so wisely said
no man ever crosses the same river twice
the man is not the same man and the
river
is not the same river and likewise is a
person's relationship with the quran
you never cross the same verse twice
you are not the same person and that
verse means something different to you
in your time and in your place and under
your circumstances
tonight or today i should say excuse me
we are
going to be speaking about surat
al-ikhlas
surutil is the third to last chapter of
the quran
it is chapter 112.
of the quran it's the chapter of the
quran
which allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
dedicated
totally and completely to himself
and to his own description subhanahu wa
ta'ala
it's the third to the last chapter it
has many virtues to it
one of those virtues is that the prophet
salallahu
[Silence]
that this chapter is equivalent to the
to a third of the quran
now what does that mean well it is
equivalent to a third of the quran
with regards to the narrative of the
quran
what is the subject matter of the quran
the subject matter of the quran is three
main things
they are the three branches of knowledge
that are found in the quran
number one allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
his names his attributes his actions
number two the commandments of allah
what he has forbidden what he has
commanded
and what the ramifications of the
fulfillment of those commandments
or the transgression of those
prohibitions are
and number three the third branch of
knowledge or the third narrative
if you will that is found in the quran
are the stories
and parables and analogies that are
given to us
the stories of the prophets and
messengers the analogies of the quran
and the life of this world
etc etc this is exactly what
is meant when the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam says
is equivalent to a third of the quran
meaning it sums up a
third of the meanings of the quran
it doesn't mean that if a person reads
surah till three times that it's taken
the place of the quran
that is an incorrect understanding that
is not what is meant by it
because surat al-fatiha for example a
person must
a thousand times it would not take the
place of reciting surat al-fatiha one
time in salah
what's meant by suratul khlos
is equivalent to a third of the quran
meaning it is equivalent to a third of
its meanings
and its narratives that it has summed up
a third of all of what the quran speaks
about
and that is that it has been completely
reserved
for the description of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
all of the names and attributes of allah
all of the descriptions of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
they branch off from this chapter of the
quran and that is why it's called surat
al-ikhlas
because if a person it's called surat
in the arabic language means the chapter
that is makes something sincere
make something purified make something
its own and what does that mean
well that means that if a person recites
this verse
these verses understands them
believes them then this person has
become
solely submissive and belonging to allah
subhanahu wa
this person's heart has now become only
for allah wa ta'ala
and that is why it is such a significant
verse
it's a verse that the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam
verse or i should say verses chapter
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would begin
his day with he would end his day with
he would begin his he would end his
tawaf around the kaaba with it
it is something that he would recite
before he went to bed at night
it is something that he would recite in
salem many m
many times and a lot and often
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would recite this
chapter of the quran along with its
sister chapter which is
suratil kafirun which is the other
surat al-ikhlas the scholars of islam
tell us that
[Silence]
which we will speak about next week in
sha allah
that these are two parts
of complete and utter submission of
allah to allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and that when an individual recites
these two chapters
and when a person believes in them and
when a person
implements them that this person has
become
a completely subservient
owned
servant of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that none of him
none of his actions none of his heart
belongs to other than allah subhanahu wa
and that is something that is very
amazing and that's something that we
should all be
working towards and that's the point
of our existence essentially
so suratul
in the morning before salat al-fajr
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would
would would pray to raka
and those two raqqa that he would pray
this is the sunnah of salat al-fajr
oftentimes he would recite in the first
surat and in the second raka he would
recite surah
that's what he would begin his day with
when he would end his day which is
in the sunnah of merib oftentimes
he would recite in the first
and in the second
and so he would begin his day and he
would
end his day in salah
reciting these two chapters of the quran
likewise whenever the prophet salallahu
whenever he would make or hajj
or circumambulate the kaaba and
circumambulate and then
pray the two rakah of circumambulation
the turaka of tawaf we see that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would recite in the first
and he would recite in the second recap
this is to show you the significance of
these
chapters
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would end his night
just before he closed his eyes to go
off into sleep he would
blow into his hands three times and
recite
and he would wipe them over all of his
body and he would do this three times
before he would go to sleep allah
etc etc there are other virtues and many
virtues that this chapter holds
now why does this chapter hold so much
virtue we spoke a little bit about that
but now we'd to get into the actual
minutia of the chapter itself
i'll first begin with reciting it in
arabic
then i will translate it in its entirety
after which we will discuss each
individual verse
and end with that inshallah
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala begins
in the correct opinion of the scholars
and this is the opinion
of sheikh islam
bismillah is an
individual
verse that marks the beginning of one
chapter and the end of another
in the quran it is an independent verse
meaning bismillah is not part of surah
till
and it's not part of
it is an independent
verse of that has been mentioned
in order to articulate the difference
between one chapter to another
in sunnah tiramiti the prophet
sallallahu
even said
that we would know the beginning of one
chapter and the ending of another when
allah would send down
bismillah
sheikh in islam says we understand from
this
that bismillah
is a is a verse of the quran because
allah would send it down
but it is an independent verse
he says
say he is allah the one
the only the individual the completely
unique
allah allah
allah the one who is completely
self-sufficient and everything must turn
to him
for its sufficiency
he neither begets nor was he begotten
he neither has offspring
nor is he the offspring of another
and there is no com comparison to him
there is nothing or anyone comparable
to he subhannah this is
four verses which from these four
verses branches off all of the names and
attributes of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
in order for us to understand this
chapter we have to understand something
and that is that when we look at the
issue of
tohit tawhid what is tahid
tahid is the act of
the oneness of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
making allah one okay
taheed is
of two types
meaning in order for a person to make
in order for a person to make and to
completely fulfill to heed
a person must
have these two types of tohit
the first type is to heed al-marifah
and the second type is
welcomed okay so what does that mean
let's unpack that now
he says and this when i say he
i mean the scholars of islam this goes
back all the way to ibn abbas
all of the scholars of islam the
significant
imma of islam have mentioned these types
of tuhid
they say that the first type of tohit is
to heed of knowledge and belief
the second type of toheed is still heed
of intention
and action right some scholars refer to
this as tohita rubabiyah without
of lordship and the tohit of warship
what does that mean meaning that
to hide
means that i believe in the names
and attributes and actions
of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that they
are particular
to he and he alone that no one else
has any part in any of the names and
attributes and actions of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
that is the first type of tohit the
second type of tohid
is the tohit of al-qasud
meaning intention and action
and that is that i worship
none other than allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
that the only one that my worship
is directed to is allah alone without
any partners subhanahu wa'ta'ala
this is an extremely important
thing to understand if we're going to
understand the quran
it's not enough to merely believe that
allah is the only creator
everybody believes that that is
something that
is a logical conclusion as a matter of
fact
and it is an illogical conclusion
and it is a logical fallacy for a person
to believe that there is more than one
creator
does not translate to there is no
creator but god there is no god but god
that is not what it means
what it translates to is there is none
who is rightfully worshipped but that
one god who is the one who created
subhanahu ta'ala and that's the point of
contention
between the prophets and messengers and
their people
when we talk about
us when we talk about
this is what surat al-ikhlas is about
it's about that first type of tahit
tahid
and belief of aruba belief in allah's
names
and attributes and actions and that they
are particular to him
he is the only creator he is the only
sustainer
he is the only one who has
the epitome of his names and attributes
subhanna
he is the only one who is unique he is
the only one who is worthy of worship
etc etc this is
so when allah begins
he's speaking to the prophet salallahu
but he's also speaking to every other
person who reads this
as if he is to say say
chant make it your mantra
continue to say to yourself
have your heart revolve around the
meanings of
who allah had he is allah
ahad now notice how he says
ahad and he didn't say even though ahad
and
are both names of allah one of the names
of allah is
and the other name of allah is subhanahu
in the arabic language has many
distinctions
that distinguish it from even though
they come from the same
source and they both essentially mean
one
however ahad
is more epitomizing
of uniqueness what does that mean
that means that when we say allah
meaning that say he is allah
one none is him in his
oneness or anything else about him
he is absolutely unique
allah and allah the name allah
literally translates to the one who is
worshipped out of love and exaltation
it's a name that is specific to allah
allah a summit
a summit in the arabic language
articulates many meanings the majority
of those meanings revolve around
as
they revolve around highness and
majesty and also a summit
meaning the one who needs no one
or needs nothing needs
needs he he does not need anyone or
anything
and everything and everyone needs him
subhanahu wa
that is the most prominent meaning of a
summit
the ones the one subhanahu ta'ala that
all of the creation turn to for their
existence for their needs
for what they for for for their
existence for them to continue to exist
their existence in itself relies upon
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
maintaining that existence for them
he then says
he neither begets nor was he begotten
meaning he has no offspring and he
is not the offspring of another he has
no beginning subhanahu
he has no end because when we as human
beings we have children
this marks the beginning of a life of
another person
and the beginning of my end because my
child will take my place
but when he subhanahu wa ta'ala says he
neither begets nor was he begotten
he has no beginning he has no end
he has no child and he is not the child
of another
none has preceded him and none will
follow him
and then he ends this all with saying
and there is none who is
in any way similar
to he subhanahu wa ta'ala
we ask allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
bless us with knowledge of the quran
to give us wisdom to remind us of it
what we have been made to forget
and to grant us understanding and
implementation of that understanding
of muhammad
thank you very much for joining us and
we will see you next week insha allah
you